it was a rejection election
voters overwhelmingly across the country
rejected these radical policies of the
democrats which have caused inflation
rising prices open borders and now they
want to raise taxes even higher
you would think this would be a wake-up
call for the democrats but they're still
sleepwalking like zombies on this road
to socialism
that was wyoming senator and gop
conference chair john barrasso on this
program earlier this month after
republican glenn yunken won the
governor's race in blue state virginia
and new jersey's democratic governor
barely held on to his seat republicans
seem to have lots of momentum ahead of
next year's midterms and our next guest
aims to keep the red wave going
minnesota congressman tom emmer is
chairman of the national republican
congressional committee and somebody i
had the honor and privilege of serving
within the united states congress uh
congressman thank you so much for for
being here i mean republicans are buoyed
but i gotta tell you they they have a
knack republicans of kind of losing that
momentum and getting off message and
snatching defeat from the jaws of
victory what what's the plan to actually
get all the way through
the tape and take back the house and the
senate
well jason first off great to see you
thanks for having me you're doing a
great job i look
i think senator barrasso i said it a few
weeks ago i'll say it again i the voters
are smart jason
americans are smart i
they are rejecting
this
socialist big government agenda
they realize that democrats in congress
right now are completely out of touch
with main street america and middle
class americans and our job over the
next year we know it's going to be a dog
fight is to make sure that it's very
clear every day that their policies
their big government policies are
driving inflation are driving the crime
wave across this country are responsible
for the open border and we can go
through all kinds of incompetent
leadership that the this administration
has shown us since the beginning of the
year
yeah i've never seen a national party be
so aggressive against first responders
law enforcement the border patrol ice
and usually this is where we have some
bipartisan support but the democrats
have been very aggressive that doesn't
seem to be the same message that they
brought into 2020. it seems as if they
got there and they they act as if they
have this green new deal mandate that i
didn't hear them talking about with the
the velocity and the veracity that they
did that they are now
look jason if you look back the trump
administration policies were incredibly
popular whether it was american energy
independence whether it was safety and
security in your communities in your
state in this country whether it was a
secure border southern border i mean
these were extremely popular and you're
correct these democrats came into office
and they basically took it as a mandate
which they're trying to undo everything
the last administration did with
terrible consequences to the american
people and that's why they're going to
lose next fall
you know one of the key metrics out
there is you look at retirements uh my
understanding is there are 17 democrats
that have have announced that they're
going to retire this year compared to 12
republicans uh as we turn the first of
the year this is usually when the most
retirement announcements come out what
do you see happening there congressman
well you look back again just a few
weeks ago you've got uh the american
people uh whether it was virginia new
york uh new jersey uh even in seattle uh
rejected this big government socialist
agenda agenda that the democrats have
been pushing forward they rejected it
completely and
they didn't back off jason
they're continuing to push this agenda
and because of that you see a lot of
retirements before thanksgiving you
mentioned the 17 a lot of these are
long-time long-serving
chairman and chairwoman of these
different committees
look we said it before the thanksgiving
holiday you're right most of these
people go home have a little time with
their families start to reassess what
the future looks like they see what's
coming we've told them
you got a decision to make either retire
now or lose next fall because
republicans will take back a majority
and we're going to fire nancy pelosi
once and for all
all right congressman please stay right
there when we come back the white house
says president biden intends to run for
re-election in 2024 but some strategists
are not so sure he'll be up for it more
after this
the white house says president biden
intends to run for re-election in 2024
but he'll be 82 years old and his
approval ratings are tanking so are
those of vice president kamala harris
amid reports of dissension between her
staff and the white house we're back
with minnesota congressman tom emmer
chair of the national republican
congressional committee congressman i
thought it was interesting a that 10
months into the administration biden had
to announce that he was running for
reelection but i don't know if that's a
huge selling point to the american
people it may have been a republican
plan was that was that your idea to get
him to announce that
no it's it's uh look he can run again in
2024 if that's what he wants to do but
he's going to lose jason
and it's not a good sign it's never a
good sign when members of your own party
are literally talking about who's going
to replace you and you haven't even been
in the job for a full year yet
the reason they're gonna lose uh they're
responsible for the inflation that we're
seeing prices are up for everything and
paychecks are down they're responsible
for this crime wave that i talked about
earlier they're doing nothing to solve
it right uh and they're responsible for
chaos on our southern border and the
incompetence just goes on and on whether
we talk about afghanistan or now this
ridiculous political ploy to release 50
million barrels of oil from the
strategic petroleum oil reserve do
people realize jason that this country
uses about 20 million barrels a day i
mean it's just one incompetent move
after another i hope he does run again
yeah less than three days of supply
congressman what's the big sleeper issue
that differentiates republicans from
democrats that they think they can win
on next year
look i the things that pop
people do not want more big government
they want less government
what do the democrats do they run on big
government in virginia they get
they get their hat handed to them and
they come back the next day jason they
say you know the problem is we didn't do
enough government
it's about putting government into the
right size that it should be it's about
competent leadership uh the incompetence
that we've seen since the beginning of
the year is causing serious problems for
middle-class americans uh frankly for
the country as a whole it's about safety
and security it's about security at our
southern border those are the issues
it's about putting people jason back in
charge of the decisions they make that
they feel are best for themselves rather
than having their government tell them
what that is
you know one of the things i see the
democrats doing time and time again is
saying well we got a messaging problem
here usually congressmen when they start
saying that there's a messaging problem
that's because the policy is failing and
it's not something that they're able to
sell
uh thank you so much for joining us
today on sunday morning futures
minnesota congressman tom emmer of the
nrcc thank you again